We're now going to learn a
little bit about gravity.
And just so you know, gravity is
something that, especially
in introductory physics or
even reasonably advanced
physics, we can learn how to
calculate it, we can learn how
to realize what are the
important variables in it, but
it's something that's really
not well understood.
Even once you learn general
relativity, if you do get
there, I have to say, you can
kind of say, oh, well, it's
the warping of space time and
all of this, but it's hard to
get an intuition of why two
objects, just because they
have this thing called
mass, they are
attracted to each other.
It's really, at least to me,
a little bit mystical.
But with that said, let's learn
to deal with gravity.
And we'll do that learning
Newton's Law of Gravity, and
this works for most purposes.
So Newton's Law of Gravity says
that the force between
two masses, and that's the
gravitational force, is equal
to the gravitational constant G
times the mass of the first
object times the mass of the
second object divided by the
distance between the two
objects squared.
So that's simple enough.
So let's play around with this,
and see if we can get
some results that look
reasonably familiar to us.
So let's use this formula
to figure out what the
acceleration, the gravitational
acceleration, is
at the surface of the Earth.
So let's draw the Earth,
just so we know what
we're talking about.
So that's my Earth.
And let's say we want to figure
out the gravitational
acceleration on Sal.
That's me.
And so how do we apply this
equation to figure out how
much I'm accelerating down
towards the center of Earth or
the Earth's center of mass?
The force is equal to-- so
what's this big G thing?
The G is the universal
gravitational constant.
Although, as far as I know, and
I'm not an expert on this,
I actually think its measurement
can change.
It's not truly, truly a
constant, or I guess when on
different scales, it can be
a little bit different.
But for our purposes, it is a
constant, and the constant in
most physics classes, is this:
6.67 times 10 to the negative
11th meters cubed per kilogram
seconds squared.
I know these units are crazy,
but all you have to realize is
these are just the units needed,
that when you multiply
it times a mass and a mass
divided by a distance squared,
you get Newtons, or kilogram
meters per second squared.
So we won't worry so much about
the units right now.
Just realize that you're going
to have to work with meters in
kilograms seconds.
So let's just write
that number down.
I'll change colors to
keep it interesting.
6.67 times 10 to the negative
11th, and we want to know the
acceleration on Sal, so
m1 is the mass of Sal.
And I don't feel like revealing
my mass in this
video, so I'll just leave
it as a variable.
And then what's the mass 2?
It's the mass of Earth.
And I wrote that here.
I looked it up on Wikipedia.
This is the mass of Earth.
So I multiply it times the
mass of Earth, times 5.97
times 10 to the 24th kilograms--
weighs a little
bit, not weighs, is a little
bit more massive than Sal--
divided by the distance
squared.
Now, you might say, well, what's
the distance between
someone standing on the
Earth and the Earth?
Well, it's zero because they're
touching the Earth.
But it's important to realize
that the distance between the
two objects, especially when
we're talking about the
universal law of gravitation, is
the distance between their
center of masses.
For all general purposes, my
center of mass, maybe it's
like three feet above
the ground, because
I'm not that tall.
It's probably a little bit lower
than that, actually.
Anyway, my center of mass might
be three feet above the
ground, and where's Earth's
center of mass?
Well, it's at the center of
Earth, so we have to know the
radius of Earth, right?
So the radius of Earth is--
I also looked it up on
Wikipedia-- 6,371 kilometers.
How many meters is that?
It's 6 million meters, right?
And then, you know, the extra
meter to get to my center of
mass, we can ignore for now,
because it would be .001, so
we'll ignore that for now.
So it's 6-- and soon.
I'll write it in scientific
notation since everything else
is in scientific notation--
6.371 times 10 to the sixth
meters, right?
6,000 kilometers is
6 million meters.
So let's write that down.
So the distance is going
to be 6.37 times 10
to the sixth meters.
We have to square that.
Remember, it's distance
squared.
So let's see if we can simplify
this a little bit.
Let's just multiply those top
numbers first. Force is equal
to-- let's bring the
variable out.
Mass of Sal times-- let's
do this top part.
So we have 6.67 times 5.97
is equal to 39.82.
And I just multiplied this times
this, so now I have to
multiply the 10's.
So 10 to the negative 11th times
10 to the negative 24th.
We can just add the exponents.
They have the same base.
So what's 24 minus 11?
It's 10 to the 13th, right?
And then what does the
denominator look like?
It's going to be the 6.37
squared times 10
to the sixth squared.
So it's going to be-- whatever
this is is going to be like 37
or something-- times-- what's
10 to the sixth squared?
It's 10 to the 12th, right?
10 to the 12th.
So let's figure out what
6.37 squared is.
This little calculator I have
doesn't have squared, so I
have to-- so it's 40.58.
And so simplifying it, the force
is equal to the mass of
Sal times-- let's divide, 39.82
divided by 40.58 is
equal to 9.81.
That's just this divided
by this.
And then 10 to the 13th divided
by 10 to the 12th.
Actually no, this isn't 9.81.
Sorry, it's 0.981.
0.981, and then 10 to the 13th
divided by 10 to the 12th is
just 10, right?
10 to the first, times 10,
so what's 0.981 times 10?
Well, the force is equal to 9.81
times the mass of Sal.
And where does this get us?
How can we figure out the
acceleration right now?
Well, force is just mass times
acceleration, right?
So that's also going to just be
equal to the acceleration
of gravity-- that's supposed to
be a small g there-- times
the mass of Sal, right?
So we know the gravitational
force is 9.81 times the mass
of Sal, and we also know that
that's the same thing as the
acceleration of gravity
times the mass of Sal.
We can divide both sides by the
mass of Sal, and we have
the acceleration of gravity.
And if we had used the units the
whole way, you would have
seen that it is kilograms meters
per second squared.
And we have just shown that, at
least based on the numbers
that they've given in Wikipedia,
the acceleration of
gravity on the surface of the
Earth is almost exactly what
we've been using in all the
projectile motion problems.
It's 9.8 meters per
second squared.
That's exciting.
So let's do another quick
problem with gravity, because
I've got two minutes.
Let's say there's another
planet called the
planet Small Earth.
And let's say the radius of
Small Earth is equal to 1/2
the radius of Earth and the mass
of Small Earth is equal
to 1/2 the mass of Earth.
So what's the pull of gravity
on any object, say same
object, on this?
How much smaller would
it be on this planet?
Well, actually let me save
that to the next video,
because I hate being rushed.
So I'll see you